let me first uh start by saying uh uh
how much i enjoyed this series and how
pissed i am i can't watch episode 8
right now oh dude wait till you see it
it's it's
it's it's uh
it is everything episode 8 is my
favorite well my my question and this is
not a spoiler related thing but you hbo
max and you you sent out the first seven
of the eight episodes was episode 8 held
back because vfx are not done or because
of spoilers
spoilers i wouldn't let them put out
eight they wanted to put out all eight i
said no way no chance in hell are we
putting out all eight i there's just too
many things happening in episode eight
that i just i could not let it get out
there it would absolutely
be spoiled you know um i wouldn't even
let them give it to like one place or
anything like that because it just
wasn't just i didn't want to be out
there
no i completely understand um uh you
mentioned i'm just gonna throw this out
there you mentioned previously that you
were doing another dc or thinking about
another dc project besides peacemaker
since no one's recording this any chance
you want to tell me
uh you know we're we're stepping forward
it keeps happening so we'll you know
we'll we'll see what's happening and uh
i'll know what's happening very shortly
i dealt with it uh last night and this
morning so
is it can i ask if it's tv or movie
stevie
i won't thank you i won't press you any
further so i [ __ ] love the opening
credits and i am just curious how long
have you been holding do you want to
taste it by wigwam
in your pocket for a project
well i've always liked that song i
didn't i never knew that i was going to
use it but somehow it did come to me
instantly when i you know
i started keeping long before the show
before i started writing the show when i
was just like planning out the show
um i started keeping a a hair metal list
of songs that i wanted to use and that
was right at the top of the list and so
it really came it seemed perfect for the
show i mean the lyrics were perfect the
sound of it was perfect um and uh and i
knew it would make for a great uh dance
routine at the beginning of the show in
an effort to vanquish the skip forward
button so that all the wonderful people
that were so hard on the show could have
their names be seen uh by the the folks
at home
it is i've watched i've watched seven
episodes i've watched those opening
credits in every episode because they're
so
good uh please tell me you have a longer
version of it
i don't i do not have a longer version
but i do love uh you know one of the
things i love about it is how it plays
differently you watch it in episode one
are you watching in episode seven where
you're coming out of a totally different
kind of scene it plays completely
differently um and that's one of the
things that i love about it that was the
choreography was done by a woman named
carissa barton um who got right away
what i wanted to do with it and was a
fantastic collaborator um so i love
eagley like everyone else is gonna love
eagley at any point during the shoot
were you like what the hell was i
thinking putting a bald eagle as his
partner no i loved it i knew he was
gonna steal the show i'm like i'm like
take it from the guy who had baby groot
or even the first group you know the
first group when we had him on set like
everybody just took it for granted that
this guy was there and then all of a
sudden the movie comes out and everybody
loves this character that nobody gave
two thoughts about on set and i'm like
eagley's gonna steal the show
everybody's gonna love eagley i'm like
you were great in that scene jen you
were amazing but unfortunately you're in
the scene with eagley so he's the one
that people are gonna be talking about
in that scene so they just have to deal
with it eagles is the true star of the
show
how was it because uh you've obviously
come from working in lower budget
environments and you've worked in
massive budget environments when you
were writing peacemaker was there any
thought in your mind about the budget or
were you sort of just writing with
whatever the hell you wanted to write
and i'll deal with it later
no i think i i i innately think about
budget while i'm writing uh always um
and uh even something like as
big-budgeted as
uh
of as valium three is still a struggle
you know it's still a struggle to make
it
fit the budget because
uh in
a movie to be half a billion dollars and
if i had half a billion dollars i could
kind of do pretty close to what i want
um
[Music]
so
that's that's how hard it is i'm always
having to think about budget and make
concessions because of budget but
oftentimes it leads to good things you
know you oftentimes are forced to
rethink something and you have to come
up with a creative solution and so
usually i think those budget
considerations uh make a difference and
we had a very good budget on peacemaker
you know um
uh you know you know so but you know but
it isn't suicide squad
um
and uh and once we didn't have the time
you know it's time to i mean i had to
shoot eight episodes before i went and
shot uh guardians and i didn't have all
the time you know in the world to do
that and especially since a couple of
changes that came up that i had to reach
to shuffle we went a little bit longer
than i originally intended to go
um
so uh
yeah but yes the answer is yes i do
think a little bit about budget it's not
a low budget show by any stretch of the
imagination um but it also you know i
had to think a little bit about what we
were shooting and when
that's the other thing is that with a
movie you might have three days to shoot
something in a peacemaker you probably
have to get it done in one day that's
right yes that is that's totally true
you know or you know for a couple days
or whatever you know i mean our action
sequences we try to take the time with
them you know um i you know i have a
philosophy on
on movie making that is uh probably my
my my best contribution to filmmaking
and that is
uh you take half of your movie to shoot
the first two acts and the other half of
the the movie you shoot the third act
um that is the way that a third act
works better than the first two acts and
most movies don't do it they structure
the same amount of time that he
structures the same amount of time
through the whole you know movie for uh
a scene you know
but i think that for a movie to really
build you need more time to shoot the
third act and i did that here too just
with some of the action sequences we
took a little more time and then the
eighth episode is pretty enormous it's
enormous
cannot wait um i'm in my last minute so
of course i'm going to ask you uh how is
the shoot going for guardians 3 and what
can you tease fans
um it's going great you know uh chuck
woody who plays mirn in peacemaker is
one of the main characters in the movie
and people are freaking out over how
good this guy is like literally freaking
out um and so i think that uh i'm really
happy i gave a bunch of scenes to
uh marvel at the beginning of uh
at the beginning right before christmas
break and uh and uh and kevin went
you know they're all really
really really stoked but also it's not
gonna be the movie people it's it's
different than what people are gonna
expect but it's uh it's it's it's a hard
road but i'm really happy with it so far
are you filming have you started filming
the holiday special yet or is that still
upcoming in the shoot it's still
upcoming in the shoot uh we were
supposed to shoot in um
uh one day in l.a uh and you know
there's too much omicron around so uh we
couldn't do it um
so we're gonna have to fit it fit it in
i haven't started yet i'm excited too
it's fun it's like the the uh
the holiday special is like
i'm almost jealous of it even though i
wrote it
because people freak out so much on how
much they love the script for the
holiday special that
that i'm almost like wait i've got this
movie here i've been working on for two
years
you love the holiday special that i
literally wrote in a very short amount
of time but you know it is really funny
and really good
your name's on both you're gonna still
get credit yeah yeah that's true listen
i gotta rap i'm just gonna say congrats
on the series for real and i wish you
nothing but the best thanks dude i'll
talk to you soon take care later